[Musique]
van zyl à 30 ans la petite ville où elle
a grandi se nomme scottsboro ça
resf
[Musique]
quinze mille habitants un immense lac
des oiseaux vous soleil
[Musique]
abondance
le mot est faible
[Musique]
il y a dans cette petite ville 64 église
dont 21 baptiste et 7 méthodiste en fait
il y en a car tout le monde
littéralement en alabama seuls 2 % des
gens se déclare athée ou agnostique
[Musique]
des ménages marocains à 14 ans val se
fait harceler à l'école on lui lance des
déchets à la figure parce qu'elle parle
ouvertement de son homosexualité et la
religion dicte des préjugés tenaces aux
enfants en alabama la loi prévoit qu'on
doit enseigner à l'école et je cite que
l'homosexualité n'est pas un mode de vie
acceptable
l'intimidation ce n'est pas le pire des
souvenirs de vent violent à scarborough
quand elle rentre de son service dans
l'armée américaine il ya quatre ans un
ami d'enfance l'invite à passer la
soirée chez lui une cathédrale
[Musique]
en alabama les statistiques sur le viol
d'un froid dans le dos un mobile par
exemple l'une des grandes villes de
l'état
on dénombre 168 viol par cent mille
habitants
c'est plus qu'en afrique du sud qui
trône en tête d'un triste palmarès
[Musique]
ascot borloo l'ex militaire porte
plainte à la police et sa cause est
entendue devant un grand jury
quand son agresseur et déclaré innocent
une décision qu'elle attribue aux
préjugés anti gay mais aujourd'hui elle
a décidé de parler du viol publiquement
sur le plu tribunes possibles
la nuit où elle a subi viols souvent
elle est tombée enceinte internet tablet
[Musique]
l'an dernier l'alabama a adopté une loi
draconienne en matière d'avortement
aucune interruption de grossesse est
tolérée même en cas d'inceste de viol
comme en syrie comme guatemala et fait
drôlement verbalement l'avortement est
légal aux états unis depuis célèbre
jugement la cour suprême en 1973 le but
de l'alabama et donc de provoquer une
bataille juridique dont l'objectif avoué
était de retourner en cour suprême et
faire casser ce jugement
dans une des rares cliniques
d'avortement de l'alabama des croyants
enflammé sont là dès le petit matin pour
intercepter les gens qui entrent sur le
terrain mais nul besoin d'aller à la
rencontre de ces prouvy tapageur pour
comprendre que le projet d'interdire
l'avortement rallye comme dieu à peu
près tout le monde ici
depuis notre visite en alabama de l'eau
a coulé sous les ponts
la cour suprême a invalidé en juin
dernier projet de loi anti avortement et
maintenant la louisiane ce qui rend
improbable une bataille entre l'alabama
et la cour fédérale sur le même sujet
les au delà de l'âge est légal
la jeune mère étaient pétrifiés à l'idée
que l'alabama
puis ce même caressé de telles idées
valent a choisi de garder l'enfant mais
avoir une garde partagée avec celui
qu'elle a accusé de viol c'est l'enfer
elle aimerait comme les oiseaux pouvoir
prendre son envol mais elle devra
revenir se poser sur ses rivages il
reconduire sa fille une semaine sur deux
[Musique]